hey I'm Courtney I'm Kevin I'm
Stephanie and together and together we
are the chicken pot PES Courtney is a
chef she's also one of my best friends
and she's written so many cookbooks
worked in incredible famous kitchens
we're so lucky to have her on the show
Making Elizabeth's food let's begin
shall
we I'm about to make the chicken pot pie
with Kevin and Stephanie and this this
is a huge huge dish on the show like
without the chicken pot pie you would
not have separate six that's right it's
the Catalyst Kevin's character Walter
takes a bite of this chicken pot pie and
it inspires him for the rest of the
series and possibly life I would like to
offer you a job as the new host of our
bla TV's latest cooking show are you
concussed but you know I know Kevin a
little bit and he has said that he is
not a good cook so I'm very excited to
see how this is going to go because I
think um he's going to learn a lot from
you today also don't think Stephanie is
a huge cook either she's so I'm really
curious to see how they
do I can't wait to find out this is so
fun
[Music]
neither I brought my chicken pot pie
recipe along with the sample so that you
can taste the crumble of the crust and
the viscosity of the filling before we
get started please do tell me just a
Teensy little bit about your characters
I play Fran fras I am the head of HR at
Hastings lab Elizabeth and I bump heads
a lot since day you got here you have
just acted like you are so much better
than the rest of us marching around
these halls with your perfect little
nose up like you invented Penicillin I
play Walter I'm a producer at supper at
6 I also bump heads with Elizabeth quite
a bit I hear your concerns um thing is
TV it needs to be inviting and fun
cooking is not fun it is vital work
we're going to start by making the
filling so we're going to come over here
you're going to dump the butter in Easy
boom all right it's already sizzling
yeah it's sizzling now we're going to
add celery carrots onions so both of you
in the show we have big careers what do
you think it's like working with your
character on the show like how do you
contribute to the work environment I
play a TV producer so having been on a
lot of TV sets we're in a room with a
bunch of different people and everybody
brings their own think to it especially
you know actors most of them have
something weird kind crazy about them I
can relate to that right now
de with Fran she's head of HR she
follows the rules she gets everybody
excited to do o we're adding in the
chicken the shredded chicken but keep
talking you're doing great I mean I can
relate to her because I think she tries
to add a lot of fun to the workplace but
she's a bit of a strict rule follower
can be probably obnoxious are you a rule
follower in real life yeah yeah mhm
really you're kind of like friend do you
relate to more than I'd like to admit
yeah there is protocol Miss do when you
don't follow protocol it falls on
me you're just going to do this and the
goal is you want it to be pretty thin
about like this I'm going to place this
here for now do you see the butter in
here so this is this is butter that's
what makes it really flaky and crispy
and delicious all right you're doing
great lots of oh it's so I'm not going
to have to do uh arms yeah you just is
it normal to throw out your back doing
this sometimes yeah uh oh wa all right
I'm going to is like so thin brother
yeah I did I make it too thin no I mean
well maybe but it's okay it's going to
work it's still going to work
great I think that if I were going to
like make a dish for somebody for like
like my husband it would be probably
just like angel hair what kind of
noodled angel hair yeah or C I like
fucili fil what's the difference there
those that's the the spirals isn't that
fili yeah I think the point of the
spirals is that the little bits of meat
go in the little grooves of the spirals
yeah I love facili what can I say I mean
did you see how well that I R this I
know I am a rule follower yes like I
said we have our dough we have our in so
we're each going to assemble one I'm
just going to cut a square about this
size to put in the bottom and I'm going
to cut around like this through the top
and you just put the pyo in the cup push
it into the bottom make sure it goes all
the way to the edges trim it so there's
just like about I don't know what is
that half an inch of an overhang All
Around The Edge just like that so do
youall want to do that okay we got the
circle circle now we got the square
we're going to place the square on top
there's nothing better than
the the feeling of cutting dough mhm I
agree is that weird no would High dough
be the same for like an actual pie or
would that be like a like a dessert pie
yeah yeah yeah so this P dough is very
versatile you can use it for Savory you
could use it for dessert yeah it's
literally just flour and butter so
really good yeah oh boy I didn't think I
was going to make it through that it
looks great thank you okay so now we're
just going to fill these literally just
get your spoon in there and fill it to
the top okay
now put the top on and then you're just
going to fold it over cute top like this
so you really want to pinch it to seal
it and then even if it doesn't seal all
the way right now we are going to egg
wash them literally you just brush the
tops with egg it is exactly what it
sounds like and then you want to vent
the pie so that the steam can escape all
right I'm going to do cool here you go
okay gorgeous and then we'll put these
in the oven and um let these bake we
give them a taste the starch goes
through a process called retrogradation
where the molecules restructure into a
crystalline form the flavor compounds
are trapped in said structure which
makes every bite more flavorful yeah I
definitely tasted the extra molecules
what do you think makes um the best
first date dinner at home picnic or
restaurant uh my fiance and I we our
first date was a picnic really that's a
really good first date mhm what about
you I would say restaurant
and I was thinking with my husband
that's a good first date was that
y'all's first date at a restaurant yeah
and it's just so romantic if you go to a
good one yeah it's nice yeah treat
yourself can I take you to dinner
tonight yes yes I would very much like
that so be careful cuz this is hot it's
like oozing out this is like the filling
and the butter just like
looking all right spoon yeah spoon is it
going to be too hot let's see ready
the color is perfect it's so perfect you
really know how to do this oh my
gosh oh my gosh m going in for another
bite oh my gosh this is so good we got
to get the crispy pastry mhm and there's
a chewiness yeah you know what I love
it's the combo you go from you break
through the crispiness and then plunge
into a chewiness more of a gooiness and
they all taste like this like chicken
Popeyes are they all this textur or is
this a special way to this is a special
one thank you so much for coming today
had so much fun it was great thanks for
teaching us yeah this was a delicious
lesson yay and you can learn more about
these characters and the food and
lessons in chemistry on Apple TV plus
yay